こんにちは stick up です2週間おきにこちらで日本語で日本その英語朝の
言葉のベージュについて話し
a していますよねでまぁ日本の前はやはり言葉の勉強というのはまあ英語の勉強の
場合が多いにつけるとそれだけじゃないですけれども
大部分の人が英語を勉強している
今は講義ないティクビ19コロナワールドの間キリンはカナダでも日本でもみんな家に
その
いないといけませんよねじゃあその時間をどうやって使おうか
僕の場合はいまーのプレッシャー号と穴子
勉強してます前よりも時間ありますから聞いたり読んだり勉強している
みなさーん
日本の方がですね英語の水温を上げたいと思った
今チャンスなんですよね普通は
仕事行ったりとかたくさん忙しい中でなかなか言葉の勉強の時間がないけれども今
時間がありますじゃその子がをどうやってその
効果的に使うかっ
その英語の文法の方も読むのは役に立ちません
えその
単語表みるのも勉強しても役に立たない
小いうような勉強方法はですね
ふーん
ま英語で言うとそのいるーじゃん
あふれテンションだから難関覚えているだろうと思いながらも
a 2語ったら全部忘れだからいいや見立てない
その言葉の勉強っていうのはもうあくまでなれ
あくまでその脳にその
まあ no 信頼して脳が勉強するからだから脳に十分な刺激十分なその
まあやはりへその言葉を聞いて読んでその脳に新しい習慣をつける
処理だけなんですよ処理以外の文法や
万学校も含めてですけれどもそんなにやってたた薬味たたい
ん例えば
その
ちっちゃな1歳2歳の
そのまあ赤ちゃんですね1年以内にですね
多分
どんな言葉でも僕号の基本の構造基本のパターンはすでにもう
認識しているはですよ分かっていますもちろんいくつかの
まだそのミスが合うけれども90%もね正しく
聞いてるわけですよ何が正しいか何が正しくないかとその一切
あるいは2歳未満の子どもが赤ちゃんが
うん
十分今がその
[音楽]
しその見分けできるんですよそりゃあ事件なんですよ事実ですよね
もちろん話しかけるときにまだ時間がありますけれども
何が正しいか何が正しくないかというのは赤ちゃんがすでに分かってるわけですよ
だから我々もやはり何が正しいか何が正しくないかしてるならばその
正しく話するの早く開発できます
まだ正しくその
言葉を認識するない第一ですよ
だから
たくさん聞いてたくさんあるんだだけでもそのピークなよう読むないように対しても一
つの戦略が一応ですこの前にもそれについて僕話ししましたけれどもやはりその脳と
いうのは新しいものが好きなんですよ新しいま
だけども繰り返しも必要
だからリンクの場合はミニストーリー繰り返して繰り返して聴いて繰り返して聴いて
うーんそういえをその掃除もしながら聴いて聴いて聴いて
それ繰り返し繰り返しだけども繰り返しが多すぎると脳が疲れる
脳がそれが面白くない何も
勉強しないだから勉強するその何ですか
a
効果がさがあるだから新しいものを面白い
だからそのマニキュアはミニストーリーを繰り返して聞くのとまた
いやいや難しいけれども面白い新しいな様も読んだり聞いたりするのが大切
そのバランスが非常に大切あの
ミニストーリーの繰り返しっていうのは処理例えば運動の場合は馬英九と英語で行こう
多いからでしょ
お腹その辺背中その辺が屋一億
粒と他の運動が伊予グラートだからその候補科挙中心部をですね
家を
するために民主党よ繰り返して聴いて読んで
だけで持ち帰るつまらないから今度新しいものをあの挑戦するそのバランスが非常に
大切
その中で時々文法に関してその疑問がある
好奇心があるその
場合は調べてみてもいいけれども調べてみったー
説明とか様がすぐ忘れるから
だけでもそれやってもいいけれどもそこに重点を叶えてください
重点はあくまで聞くと読む
それを集中的に今
一つキーカー何週間かこの家にその
残らないといけないという事情の中で一生懸命それを
まあできるだけ楽しくたくさん聞いたり読んだりするが英語にしろ
あるいはん
中国語を勉強している方スペイン語を勉強している方
やはりかなりの進歩があの可能なんですよ
でその進歩というのはその脳のそういう新しい言葉に対するなれな女ができる
なれができたらその上でやはり
台湾の能力とか彼曰くのうんその
何ですかまぁ能力ですねなんだあの関越できます
だから友好的に今の
その時間営
利用してくださいじゃそういうことで同5
4なら